et attention si vous n'êtes mots compris
mon gars scrabble 17 bon mec tu avec moi
qui dis pas johan mois plus tôt à
puissance 4 c'est beaucoup ont compliqué
c'est mort il ya un jeu dans le monde où
pourrait jouer tous les deux bapt être
que ça lui le jeu parfait qui n'existe
pas ça ressemble à quoi un jeu parfait
bah franchement déjà ce sera un jeu qui
va de place ouais il y aurait pas des
jetons il y aurait des cartes
ouais mais du coup c'est quoi moi je
sais pas il faudrait imaginer que c'est
ça non mais imaginez un jeu où on
pourrait imaginer des trucs images ici
on pouvait se commit haut et on pourrait
importer des trucs pas ouais et il y
aurait un arbitre et direct qui gagne
c'est pas gagné
ouais mais il a un beau t-shirt
ouais des genres la seule limite ça
serait ton imagination et comme le
niveau de l'eau il augmenterait sans
cesse du coup la pression exercée sur
les portes et c'est trop fort pour les
ouvrir avec des beatles live tu imagines
si on n'avait qu'un seul doit aller bien
faire contre ailleurs je m'excuse de la
gueule tu besoin puissent un jour
seraient tous ensemble en harmonie en
ces mots et gens même s'ils ont fait des
vannes qui parfois pas vexant il va
c'est pas bien mais 90 est vraiment très
points de mu marcel et moi ça me gêne
trop quoi non ça me gêne mais qu'on leur
dit d'acheter 20 fois c'est même c'est
important c'est important mais c'est pas
grave si les gens mangeaient pas moins
déjà thème le nombre d'offres on a passé
à faire ce jeu tu as genre écrire toutes
les cartes ont été brouillons etc
ensuite si le projet marche ça veut dire
qu'il ya peut-être d'autres gens qui
vont nous faire confiance pour faire
d'autres projets etc
ça veut dire aussi peut-être plus de
buts pour les vidéos de la chaîne etc
ça veut dire que là si les gens ils
précommande dès maintenant sur amazon
servez libraires vont voir que ça marche
et du coup en acheter pour leur libre
etc c'est un effet boule de neige c'est
hyper important c'est aussi une preuve
de soutien pour la chaîne enfin c'est
c'est hyper-important mec
le castellet ouais 450 car de deux à
douze joueurs trois manches de jeu et le
lien pour le précommander dans la
description partir on espère vraiment
que ces opéras on aimait beaucoup d'une
autre bisous bisous